who watched the State of the Union last
night did you watch that this guy was
booing one guy started booing and then
everyone else like we better boo also
it's not all about I just said State of
the Union that's part of our it's a
tradition sure you don't boo a tradition
just wanted there just want to belong
yeah I didn't watch it I didn't watch
the State of the Union yeah yeah I was
busy binge watching love Island I don't
know if you see that show has anyone
seen that show oh man that show is
amazing have you seen it I have not seen
it's a British show where everybody has
sex it's a reality show called love
island yeah is a thing called the porn
hub that's kind of a sample does anyone
does anyone have a pen all right if you
write it down great okay I'll text it to
you yeah no just this show pornhub you
got to watch it I'm the poor yep
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you don't need the pen no you don't need
the I don't need a pen yeah
those will be my dying words all my
family will be gathered around me yeah I
was watching that show love Island check
it out it's a pretty amazing British
show okay everyone's running around in
bikinis they all have sex I love it
because they all discuss STDs in a
cockney accent Oh favorite that's nice
yeah
dripping in it I've got gonorrhea all I
do all day I wasn't any of that Mary
Poppins